There are several ways the analyst try
to identify outliers more methodically
rather than simply eyeballing them.
One way is a box and whisker plot.
With this visualization, we can make use
of the general rule of thumb that says
is a value is one a half times
the interquartile range of a data set,
then it can be considered an outlier.
Now we just threw in the mix
the term interquartile
range which may not be
familiar to all of us.
So let's take a look at what
that looks like and means.
Here we have a simple box and
whisker plot
that uses our same income data example
that we built out the histogram with.
Let's quickly review the components
to this visualization.
The line in the middle is
the median of your data.
It's the mid point value when
you line up all of your data.
Then we have the two lines that
identify the 1st and 3rd quartiles.
Each of these are essentially
the medians of the bottom half and
top half of our data.
Everything in between,
shown in the orange box,
falls into the interquartile range.
Its value is the difference between
the third quartile value and
the first quartile value.
And according to our rule of thumb
definition, if a point is more than one
and a half times the interquartile
range above the third quartile or
below the first quartile,
we would consider it an outlier.
To demonstrate how you
would determine whether or
not a value is an outlier, I've included
an example in the area below the video.
In the case of our data, all of
the data except one point up here in
the circle stops at 100,000, so
that's where the line is drawn.
But from this diagram, we can see
how our data is distributed and
where the extreme values are.
One other visualization that's
becoming more recognized
that we won't cover in detail, but we
should be aware of is the violin plot.
As we can see, it has similar components
as the box and whisker plot, but
it adds in a component that shows the
volume of the distribution of the data
indicated by the the width
of the blue area.
I like to think of it as combining,
the aspects of a histogram
with the box and whisker plot.
So as to provide a more
complete view of the data.